foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
all right there we go Pollo De La Brasa
and Aggie Verde and papitas also known
as rotisserie chicken french fries and
funky green mayonnaise sauce here try a
french fry
and take out the green sauce you don't
want to try the green sauce eat the
green sauce eat it eat it those green
sauce is amazing uh you can make it a
lot spicier and usually it is but my
family's not much into spice so I've
only got a little touch of Jalapeno in
there
oh that is perfect
perfectly done all the way through but
not overdone
so moist
um
[Music]
well that is good now of course you can
put a bird on a rotisserie and just sit
there and turn it and turn it and turn
it all day long but if you don't want to
do that spatcocking a small bird laying
it flat cooking on a rock works very
well oh man this is good stuff
I'm no Pollo Rico but you know it's
you're close looks good not too shabby
for doing it on the campfire huh
well I hope you enjoyed watching this as
much as I enjoyed eating it if you want
to see more great campfire cooking
videos check out the link in the
description we got tons of it we got a
whole playlist of videos about cooking
great meals over an open fire thanks for
watching and don't forget to click
subscribe
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching